ganz traurige geschichte ein sieben
jahre altes mädchen von einer marmor
säule erschlagen ein tragischer unfall
passiert ist das hier in diesem münchner
hotel da spielte sie eben noch hier im
garten des hotels und ihr vater saß
neben dran sie spielte dort mit einem
kleinen jungen und dann ging alles ganz
schnell und unfassbar trage schief ja
eine 200 kilo marmorsäulen so eine
statue ist dort dann umgefallen als die
kleine lavinia mit einem anderen kleinen
jungen dort gespielt hat und die
marmorsäulen ist direkt auf lavinia
drauf gefallen schreie noch dort dann
sind hotelgäste herbeigeeilt haben sie
irgendwie geschafft von dieser säule von
dieser statue zu befreien aber sie ist
wenig später dann im krankenhaus an
ihren schweren verletzungen gestorben
ihre mama die hat noch ein paar
bewegende worte gepostet für ihre kleine
lavinia sie hat geschrieben du bist und
bleibst unser engel ruhe in frieden die
liebe unseres lebens lavinia
[Musik]